are you the eye doctor i'm the  everything doctor toes backs [ __ ]  hey  i remember you  i've seen you around a lot what is it  this time ah i got into a fight  busted my nose  what does your father say about your  nose um well my dad's really not here  that often so is your mom  remarried  well why just bedside mandar relax bear  everything's good  so you got beat up actually i got jumped  it's because i'm the leader of a gang  you know big responsibilities yeah  way to get older life gets much harder  look at me you think i like having this  job  you think i wanted to be out here this  long ten [ __ ] years i don't have a  family i got nothing don't get me wrong  i love the native american people very  sweet majestic very special  try to grow this out i'm sick of it i  just want to go back from where i'm from  china  no you [ __ ]  i grew up in san diego